I remember the first day you walked in
all pissed off and angry you want
somebody huh reminded me of me so
roughly it come on everybody's gotta
have a reason but it's like Oh why'd you
come well I want a box a box but why do
you want fight we get a few issues we
had to discuss yeah American boxes
Commission they don't want you to fight
they want me to shave my beard there is
one way to fix this what's that do as
they ask I couldn't it's the tradition
the ABC will argue it's their tradition
that fighters my shave this is who I am
I have to fight for we think this is not
the argument about race or religion
maintaining the health and safety of
their fighters is the ABCs primary
concept is the ABCs clean shave rule
prejudicial yes it is this meeting is
adjourned
your training will get you to regionals
nobody likes change
amia done with a matter how a fighter
look it ain't gonna knock me down
I don't want to be that guy that was a
sport he loves or ruins it for you at
the other fighter you want to quit be a
quitter
there's only one way you do anything do
they work harder than the rest your it
up discipline and you do that gotta love
yourself you do
[Music]
you chose to fight you are a heel
there's so much to admire in you you
can't even see it for yourself the
question is does the American boxing
commissions tradition trump that of mr.
nog restate don't all ward knows about
you they call you the Punjab tiger
[Music]
any last-minute advice hit him more than
he hits youth
you
[Music]
you